en direct du plus beau village
ça brûle ou l'avait déjà fait c'est plus
rare que les chercher henri iv pour nous
le démontrer
nous sommes quand même convaincu qu'il a
raison et nous partageons ce sens de
l'esthétique un seul président du
conseil général
madame combien général christian
poncelet généraux mesdames messieurs les
maires d'avis que les élus mesdames
messieurs monsieur le président de la
fondation d'aujourd'hui et de demain
bienvenue ici dans notre département
avec tous les élus rassemblés autour du
président berthod pour un roman très
fort merci à bruno de nous avoir parlé
avec son esprit ce n'est le temps c'est
nickel mais surtout de faire prendre
cette énergie qu'il a qui n'a sans doute
tirer de ce terroir dont on sait qu'ils
fournissent et l'énergie et le caractère
bruno est doté d 2 nous sommes très
heureux d'être sur ce projet beaucoup de
choses ont été dites je vais être rapide
mais il y a deux ou trois idées majeures
la première ce bruno non seulement la
dit rien c'est que le social c'est un
investissement on entend clairement
toujours aujourd'hui dire que le social
c'est de la dépense le social c'est un
investissement d'abord pensons à notre
territoire c'est un investissement
d'aménagement du territoire puisque les
financements sont en partie nationaux et
qu'ils sont répartis localement et donc
à partir du moment où il ya une
redistribution ceux qui ont beaucoup
d'initiatives territoriales bénéficient
d'une part de la solidarité nationale
donc à un système de péréquation qui
quand même assez juste parce qu'il
récompense le dynamisme et les idées et
au fond il n'ya là quand même quelque
chose de fort c'est à dire qu'il y à cet
encouragement à avoir décidé à porter
des projets je crois que ce soit pour
les personnes âgées ou le département en
quelques années à rattraper le retard
qu'il avait au début des années 2000 et
nous sommes aujourd'hui maintenant en
équipements au niveau national un niveau
satisfaisant il est vrai que pour
l'enfance c'est une stratégie globale
qui était celle du département avec nos
débats nourris que alain fouché et
claude bertaud ont suivi notamment parce
que vous restez dans le département de
france qui fait plus pour l'éducation
des jeunes pour la mobilisation de la
formation qui reste quand même cet
investissement sur la jeunesse qui est
prioritaire
au fond cette détermination sociale qui
dans la caractéristique de ce
département il est très important de
l'avoir toujours comme un investissement
même si naturellement ça mobilise des
moyens mais c'est une stratégie qu'il ne
faut jamais abandonner surtout quand on
est un territoire fragile et surtout
quand il y a tout autour de nous la
crise aujourd'hui on sent le pays un
pied on sent souvent les forces
démoralisés aujourd'hui nous avons sans
doute ce que l'action publique fait de
plus beau c'est à dire une action
sociale au service de l'enfance merci
bruno du fond du coeur parce que même si
la stratégie là il faut un moment donné
quelqu'un qui la gagne et qu'il porte en
étant médiateur aussi bien vis-à-vis des
acteurs nationaux que des classeurs
départementaux donc que de ce beau pays
vinet et de teint comme une demande donc
merci a toi deuxième merci il est pour
les donateurs de la fondation qui sont
ici présents je vais insister sur ce
point parce que vous c'est une de mes
satisfactions d'anciens premiers
ministres il ya eu l'effet du quart
d'heure mais ya quand même eu quelques
moments et notamment le fait d'avoir
créé ses statuts et nouveaux qui
permettent par un fisc l'idée d'avoir
des investissements assez fort par les
fondations je pense que ça c'est très
important excès l'avenir il n'est pas
normal que la france par rapport à
d'autres pays ne savent pas cultiver sa
générosité et ne ça pour mieux partager
les énormes personnel des années des
sceaux et grâce aux actions des
fondations on peut aujourd'hui s'engager
personnellement dans des actions où on
engage sa responsabilité
c'est bien d'avoir des idées et que pour
ceux qui ont les moyens bien sûr de
faire en sorte qu'ils aillent jusqu'au
bout de lances des jusqu'à l'action
personnelle je crois que c'est très
important et que ça changera beaucoup
dans les années qui viennent je pense
que beaucoup d'établissements de
formation seront financées en partie par
des fondations avec des anciens élèves
car si l'argent public se fera de plus
en plus rares il va falloir faire appel
à toutes les formes de solidarité
d'engagement personnel et le tout avec
toutes les rigueurs de la bonne gestion
mais aussi avec l'élan du coeur sans
lequel il n'ya pas véritablement
solidarité c'est pour ça que je crois
que la démarche globale des fondations
est appelé à se développer et nous
devons nous devons l'encourager
et pour cela il faut savoir exprimer
notre gratitude pour tous ceux qui
s'engagent dans une action note des
actions plus grande que qui les portent
vers des ambitions fortes étant nous
pouvons bénéficier dans des initiatives
comme ça plus les choses iront plus nous
aurons des tours de table mesdames et
messieurs les maires on en parle souvent
nous aurons des tours de table dans
lequel il faudra trouver de l'argent
privé qui sous des formes de l'intérêt
général comme la fondation viennent
participer ce n'est pas parce que
l'argent et privés il est indifférent à
l'intérêt général et c'est pour ça qu'on
a besoin d'outils de cette nature et de
mettre autour de la table à côté des
acteurs institutionnels
ce type d'acteur ce qui transforme est
élue ce que nous sommes des arbres dans
ce département en ingénieur projet qui
essaie de bâtir des tours de table
capable d'avoir à une vraie réalisation
c'est ce qui se fait ici et qui est très
important enfin je voudrais saluer
cette action spécifique pour des
fratries qui connaissent ce qu'il ya
sans doute de plus durs dans la vie d'un
enfant la séparation avec les parents
dans des conditions encore et c'est sans
doute ce qu'il ya de plus déchirant dont
on sait l'importance que peut avoir dans
une famille un père une mère et que tu
que cet entourage à un moment se trouve
fracturée et quelquefois même dans les
cas de violence difficile à supporter
quand la justice s'est prononcée que la
société là à ce moment là phase iii de
capacité un revers ses enfants de nous à
les aider à s'épanouir dans ce très beau
village et avec un environnement qui
leur permettra de trouver l'énergie et
au fond c'est ça le plus belle les
humanistes ses dauphins de prendre
quelqu'un en difficulté c'est le plus
beau des investissements pour un
territoire comme nous puisque la
richesse sont les hommes et les femmes
du territoire de faire en sorte que ces
jeunes gens sont là vont pouvoir grandir
se développer et nous l'espérons
s'intégraient pour pouvoir ensuite créer
développer et le même participé à
l'énergie c'est la plus belle de toute
l'énergie les énergies humaines donc au
fond c'est le plus beau de tous les
investissements donc là ça n'a rien à
voir avec une attitude de dépendre nous
voyons bien que dans un département
comme le nôtre ce qui nous pourrait nous
arriver de pire
c'est le déclin démographique cédant
fond le vieillissement des populations
réticentes nous serions capables
d'injecter des forces nouvelles c'est ce
pourquoi le bâton et c'est pour ça que
l'enfance c'est pour nous une mission
non seulement nécessaire parce que c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus grand nous c'est
notre propre année mais c'est aussi la
capacité de tottenham territoire des
intelligences des coeurs qui feront
l'avenir
donc bruno je vais te dire dans la vie
publique ya en effet des moments plus
grands les uns que les autres mais
aujourd'hui tout nous donne l'occasion
d'avoir cette émotion qui fait que tout
ce qui se passe autour de ce projet et
bien finalement ce sera pour nous tous
une fierté partagée en deux la doua
remercie